sony is challenging apple with their own  open earbud design so today we'll see  just how good it is and how it compares  to apple's new airpods 3. the case  quality feels quite nice and it's  interesting to see a little button  that's kind of like a latch for holding  the little top open the footprint of the  link buds case is smaller but then if we  look at the sides this thing is thick  they feel a lot lighter than the airpods  3. we're gonna go through three  different tracks different styles of  music  i can't get into it i can't get into the  music at all  these things cost the same price as  airpods 3 but the battery life is quite  a bit worse the talk time is almost half  you don't have wireless charging and the  sound quality you can't even compare  it's not even close personally i would  not purchase them if you don't want to  buy air pods get the samsung galaxy buds  live